überreste eines gefängnisses versunken
in eiskaltem wasser
warum wurde das gelände geflutet was war
da
ein vergessener tummel der tief in einem
berg führt
dieses loch entfällt wird wie der
eingang zur unterwelt nur
ein seltsamer militärkomplex versteckt
im wald
auf den ersten blick glaubt man zu
wissen was es ist aber wenn man näher
hinschaut passt das alles nicht zusammen
und ein gigantisches industriedenkmal an
der mittelmeerküste
die hochbahn endet abrupt denn diese
muss riesigen krater
[Musik]
sie zählten einmal zu den
fortschrittlichsten bauten ihrer zeit
mit das modernste was ingenieurs und
baukunst zu bieten hatten
dann wurden die anlagen oft gegeben
manche sind heute lebensgefährlich
verseucht wer hat sie errichtet und wie
und warum wurden sie aufgegeben
[Musik]
estlands am nordöstlichen rand des
baltikums an einem see liegt ein
gebäudekomplex mit bewegter
vergangenheit
[Musik]
die anlage erstreckt sich über ein
großes gebiet sogar bis ins wasser
[Musik]
das sich so seltsam aus da ist diese
idyllische see und mittendrin dieses
betongebäude
die natur holt sich das gelände zurück
das hat schon fast etwas apokalyptisches
unter wasser ist die szenerie noch
gespenstischer alte maschinen
stacheldraht und mauer mit lange
erloschenen flutlichtanlagen
[Musik]
ein graffiti beschmiert das gebäude ragt
wie eine klippe aus dem wasser
und direkt dahinter ist so ein komischer
hügel er gar nicht in die flache
landschaft passt
welches geheimnis wird dieser
zerklüftete hang
ist das ein hinweis warum dieser anlage
aufgegeben wurde
niemand war hier freiwillig
die geschichte ist eng mit der zeit ist
lanz als teil der sowjetunion verknüpft
die seit 1918 unabhängigen baltischen
staaten kommen 1939 durch den hitler
stalin pakt erneut und der russischen
einfluss im juni 1940 marschierte die
rote armee erst in litauen dann in
lettland und estland 1
schon einen monat später werden durch
schein wahlen pro sowjetische parlamente
bestimmt die pumpt um anschluss an
moskau bitten
termin lässt gegner des kommunistischen
regimes in massen deportieren oder
ermorden er will das baltikum sowie
sieren
auf dem annektierten gebiet werden große
infrastrukturprojekte angeschoben dafür
müssen baumaterial und rohstoffe leer
und hier kommt die mysteriöse anlage am
see ins spiel
dies ist das berüchtigte gefängnis
aber was hat es mit den sowjetischen
bauprojekten zu tun
nach der besetzung durch die sowjetunion
wurde es für die baltischen staaten
schnell richtig hart besonders für
estland
jeder der kritik an den job jetzt äußert
landet im knast und
[Musik]
das war eines der schlimmsten
gefängnisse in ganz europa
niemand war ihr freiwillig
die gefangenen wurden schlecht behandelt
und mussten unter unmenschlichen
bedingungen schuften
es war ein ort der strafe
und die strafe war sehr hart
gefängnisse waren in der sowjetunion
keine reinen haftanstalten sondern oft
auch brutale arbeitslager
aber was mussten die häftlinge hier
erdulden
dieser teil estland ist für seine
steinbrüche berühmt der kalkstein von
dort lässt sich gut verarbeiten
[Musik]
die reine rinnsteine sind wie marmor
sehr hell in der farbe und mit wenig ein
schlüssel für den einsatz in der zement
oder papierindustrie ist es der perfekte
kalkstein
schon unter der estnischen regierung
wird 1938 beim dorf romo ein tagebau
eingerichtet mit einem gefängnis
speziell für die arbeit im steinbruch
die insassen sollen kalkstein abbauen
die größe des bizarren hügels zeigt wie
viel hier abgebaut wurde
eine halde im bergbau besteht aus dem
gestein dass man bei der förderung nicht
haben will wenn in einem tagebau etwa 50
des gesteins nutzbar ist und die andere
hälfte nicht dann türmt sich der abraum
im lauf der zeit fast zu kleinen bergen
auf
moment ins
schweres gerät zum abbauen des
kalksteins hatten die gefangenen
allerdings nicht
[Musik]
das gestein wurde mit dynamit
abgesprengt soll dann eingesammelt das
ist der grund weshalb das gefängnis
direkt neben dem steinbruch steht zum
steine klopfen braucht man rohe gewalt
das material muss kleiner werden
hier hat man eine menge arbeitskräfte
zur verfügung man braucht dafür ja keine
ausbildung sie können die brocken direkt
vor ort klein hacken
ideal für die betreiber für die insassen
die hölle hohe zäune mit stacheldraht
sollen eine flucht unmöglich machen
aber ein ganz anderes problem gefährdet
den erfolg der operation
wenn man immer tiefer gräbt stößt man
irgendwann auch schwierigkeiten zum
beispiel wenn man das grundwasser
erreicht genau das ist auch in rom
passiert
der wassereinbruch könnte die ganze
produktion zum erliegen bringen
pumpen sollen das verhindern
hier im tagebau zu schuften war absolute
knochenarbeit im winter herrschen meist
minusgrade ständig brach wasser ein das
abgepumpt werden musste es gab kaum
etwas zu essen das waren absolut
unsägliche arbeitsbedingungen
an dem vielen grundwasser das hier nach
oben drückt sieht man wie tief sie
damals abbauten
das gefängnis war ursprünglich nur für
400 insassen vorgesehen aber das reichte
nicht zur planerfüllung mehr
arbeitskräfte mussten her und die
sowjetischen machthaber wussten auch
woher die kommen würden
bei arbeitskräftemangel hatten die
sowjets eine einfache lösung
zwangsarbeit
es ging um jobs die kaum jemand
freiwillig machen wollte auch nicht für
geld schwerste knochenarbeit die einen
krank macht also zwang sie sie dazu sie
steckten sie ins gefängnis und sagten an
die arbeit
immer wenn viele arbeiter gebraucht
wurden gab es eine verhaftungswelle
zb wegen vandalismus oder störungen der
öffentlichen ordnung
laut einem bericht gab es in der region
drei arbeitslager mit insgesamt
5200 gefangen
[Musik]
viele insassen starben wegen der
grausamen behandlung unterernährung und
fürchterlichen arbeitsbedingungen
aber warum steht der horror knast heute
unter wasser
als der kalte krieg vorbei war und
estland unabhängig wurde gab es keinen
politischen grund mehr den tagebau
weiter zu betreiben
es war ein ort von tod und unterdrückung
also gab man ihn auf
nach dem zerfall der sowjetunion
verbessern sich die haftbedingungen im
büro gefängnis die zeiten der
zwangsarbeit sind vorbei der tagebau ist
geschichte auch die pumpen werden
abgestellt
wenn man unterhalb des
grundwasserspiegels abbaut muss man
ständig pumpen damit die grube nicht
verläuft sobald man die pumpen abstellt
steigt das wasser
das wasser steigt schnell die gebäude
und einige maschinen bleiben ein
verstehen und werden geflutet der rest
der haftanstalt wird noch 20 jahre
weiterbetrieben
ende 2012 schließt das moro gefängnis
für immer
heute erinnert es uns an ein grausames
regime und sein berüchtigtes
strafvollzugssystem
[Musik]
im us-bundesstaat virginia fünf
kilometer östlich der kleinstadt
salisbury verbirgt sich etwas seltsames
im wald
[Musik]
ein vergessene tunnel der tief in die
blue ridge mountains führt
stehst vor diesen gähnendes loch im berg
das aussieht wie der eingang zur
unterwelt
und wenn man reinkommt sieht man nur
einen gott der sich in der dunkelheit
verliert
eineinhalb kilometer entfernt öffnet
sich im dichten wald ein zweiter eingang
das hat etwas ziemlich gruseliges da
will man alleine lieber nicht zu tief
rein gehen
wenn man doch ins innere des berges geht
stößt man plötzlich auf eine massive
wand
waren die beiden gänge einmal
miteinander verbunden und wofür wurden
sie gebaut
um diese fragen zu beantworten muss man
rum 200 jahre in der geschichte der usa
zurückgehen es ist der beginn der
industrialisierung neue erfindungen wie
die dampfmaschine die eisenbahn und die
telegrafie ermöglichen kommunikation und
handel über weite strecken und
schließlich durch das ganze große land
[Musik]
die neuen transportrouten und fabriken
bewirken in teilen des landes einen
großen aufschwung
[Musik]
die städte an der ostküste boomen aber
jenseits der blue ridge mountains kommt
der neue wohlstand nicht an die
mächtigen appalachen zu denen der
gebirgszug gehört sind eine natürliche
barriere
[Musik]
die berge sind gar nicht besonders hoch
aber sie bestehen aus super hartem altem
gestein metamorphen und granit das ist
einfach ein sehr schwieriges terrain
bekam sie
zwei möglichkeiten darüber zu kommen
entweder über einen kanal mit nervtötend
langsamen sechs kilometern pro stunde
oder man ließ sich in einer kutsche
durch schütteln
ein tunnel system soll die reisezeit
verkürzen die pläne sind schnell
entworfen
1850 beginnt der bau nach einem
neuartigen
konstruktionsprinzip es ist hoch und
schmal fünf meter breit und sechseinhalb
meter hoch
ist das eher ungewöhnlich sonst hat man
immer gleichmäßig runde bögen
ist die kühne warum eine gute idee
[Musik]
der experte alan hale weiß einiges über
diesen ort
[Musik]
ursprünglich sollten kanäle gebaut
werden aber gegen mitte des neunzehnten
jahrhunderts ging man mit dem transport
auf die schiene
die gleise müssen fast eineinhalb
kilometer tief durch den berg getrieben
werden der französische ingenieur
clodius kruse ist für den bau
verantwortlich der tunnel wird später
seinen namen tragen
ein meisterwerk der ingenieurskunst
sie schufen das alles von hand mit blut
schweiß und tränen war ja und ein
bisschen schwarzpulver
aber wohin sind die gleise verschwunden
und was soll die wand mitten im tunnel
[Musik]
wenn man einen tunnel durch einen berg
bauen will kommt es vor allem aus
gestein an ideal ist ein fels der weich
genug ist dass man ihn bearbeiten kann
und auch hart genug für einen stabilen
tunnel in den blue ridge mountains ist
das tatsächlich nicht so einfach denn
der fels ist ziemlich fest es gibt mit
amor feed und granit diese super
wie fühlt man sich von hand durch fast
anderthalb kilometer filz
die technologie für den tunnelbau damals
lässt sich überhaupt nicht mit dem
vergleichen was es heute gibt sie
schafften im schnitt vielleicht 30
zentimeter brutal
dieser tunnel wurde von hand geburt
man sieht noch überreste der bohrlöcher
da oben an der wand
einmal schwang den vorschlaghammer und
ein anderer hielt dem bohrer der sich in
den fels drehte
höchstens 90 cm tief dann kam das
schwarzpulver da rein
schwarzpulver ist wahnsinnig gefährlich
im besten falle ist es nur unberechenbar
viele arbeiter haben das nicht überlebt
aber im bergbau noch mehr gefahren
wenn man einen felsen tunnel gerät muss
man auch veränderungen im gestein achten
manchmal liegen zwei unterschiedliche
gesteinsarten aufeinander oder es gibt
verwerfungen und risse da kann wasser
einlaufen und stellen an denen wasser
durchsickerte könnten brüchig sein
[Musik]
in diesem teil des tunnels zogen wie zum
beispiel eine dicke ziegelmauer ein
damit er sicher und stabil blieb
die gefahr eines steinschlags war
allgegenwärtig und tatsächlich wurden
auch viele dadurch verletzt oder getötet
allein durch sprengstoff unfälle sterben
mehr als ein dutzend menschen im korsett
und noch viel mehr arbeiter werden
verletzt
wenn wir jetzt hier durchgehend sieht
man den nackten massiven fels
dies noch alles genau so wie damals in
den 1850
[Musik]
die tour stehen enorm unter zeitdruck
mehrere eisenbahngesellschaften
konkurrieren um den besten und
schnellsten weg nach westen die
herrschaften von beiden seiten
gleichzeitig das design des tunnels
bietet dabei einen vorteil
[Musik]
die idee war trotz der schwierigen
bedingungen im harten fels an jedem
punkt ein maximum an abraum
herauszuholen die leute zweifelten an
großes entwurf sie dachten das kann
nicht funktionieren
[Musik]
durch die hohe schlanke form können zwei
crews von jeder seite gleichzeitig im
tunnel arbeiten das sogenannte kopf team
macht den anfang und arbeitet sich von
der decke aus vorwärts
das fuß team arbeitet sich von unten
heran
dadurch soll sich die bauzeit halbieren
aber werden sich die beiden hälften auch
in der mitte treffen
[Musik]
fast sieben jahre sind seit baubeginn
vergangen die arbeiter haben sich
buchstäblich die knochen aufgerieben sie
haben mit minderwertigem sprengstoff
gearbeitet ein rekord kalten winter und
die cholera überstanden
und jetzt ist es soweit der durchbruch
durch ein rund fünf zentimeter großes
loch können sie in die andere tunnel
hälfte spanien
sie trafen sich wirklich fast genau dort
wo sie laut berechnungen rauskommen
mussten mit nur ein paar zentimeter
abweichung eine unglaubliche leistung
für die damalige zeit
bei seiner eröffnung 1858 ist der blue
ridge tunnel mit 1300 metern der längste
tunnel in der neuen welt
jetzt können waren viel schneller von
der ostküste nach westen gebracht werden
[Musik]
im lauf der zeit werden frachtzüge und
personenwagen aber immer größer rossis
geniale tunnelkonstruktion ist
irgendwann überholt
[Musik]
aber wenn durch den tunnel einmal züge
gefahren sind warum sind die beiden
schacht hälften heute voneinander
getrennt
der tunnel sollte in den 1950 er jahren
zu einem lager für propangas werden
sie bauten ein schott aus stahlbeton mit
dem 600 meter tunnel im inneren
abgetrennt wurden
das projekt wurde aufgegeben aber die
wand im inneren blieb stehen
mittlerweile gibt es pläne den tunnel
ans rad und wanderweg wieder zu eröffnen
heute erinnern die gähnenden tunnel
eingänge an dem wagemut der ingenieure
und die opfer wie die arbeiter für die
umsetzung bringen mussten
[Musik]
ein wirklich sinnvoller bau der dem land
und seiner wirtschaft half ich bewundere
die beteiligten für die hartnäckigkeit
mit der sie das projekt umgesetzt haben
[Musik]
finnlands in einem verschneiten wald 45
kilometer nördlich der hauptstadt
helsinki
verstecken sich zwischen den bäumen zwei
türme
[Applaus]
es sind zwillingstürme absolut identisch
und absolut verlassen
auf den ersten blick denkt man an zwei
typische kirchen aus dem mittelalter
aber irgendetwas stimmt nicht nur
wenn man ganz nah ran geht sieht man
dass sie nicht aus stein sind sondern
aus beton sie müssen aus dem zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts ein
[Musik]
die anlage steht seit jahrzehnten leer
verriegelt und verrammelt
gibt es hier ein düsteres geheimnis dass
die anwohner gerne verdrängen möchten
die mauern wirken wie für die apokalypse
gemacht
der turm ist super massiv gebaut
bombenfest und wenn man hinauf an die
spitze steigt kommt man zu einer
plattform
von dieser plattform aus sieht man das
dorf brian mcewen der 7000 seelen ort
wird von einem großen industriegebäude
dominiert
der turm könnte von einer burg sein und
erfüllt auch genau den gleichen zweck
man hat von oben eine gute sicht auf die
umgebung aber hier geht es vor allem
darum dass man auch den luftraum gut
überwachen kann
aber warum braucht man so etwas in der
ländlichen einöde finnlands
der schlüssel zum geheimnis die
zwillingstürme liegt in einem oft
vernachlässigten kapitel des zweiten
weltkriegs ende november 1939 drei
monate nach kriegsbeginn marschiert die
sowjetunion in finnland ein der
sogenannte winterkrieg beginnt ausgelöst
durch besitzansprüche dies darin auf
gebiete in karelien an der finnischen
grenze erhebt
[Musik]
offiziell begründet muss für die
forderungen mit sicherheitsbedenken zum
schutz des wichtigen hafens von wenigen
grad die stadt liegt rund 30 kilometer
von finnland entfernt
die führung in helsinki lehnt die
forderungen ab und die rote armee
marschiert ein
bei temperaturen von minus 40 grad
celsius gelingt es den finnen zunächst
die angreifer zurück zu drängen aber die
russen sammeln sich und stellen ihre
truppen um die finnen sind was mann und
material angeht hoffnungslos unterlegen
ihren etwa 30 panzern stehen rum 2000
der sowjets entgegen
sie brauchen dringend eine gute
verteidigung
fürst darlehen war es absolut undenkbar
dass ein land von der größe finnlands
mit einer handvoll einwohner einfach
nein zur sowjetunion sagen könnte aber
die finnen waren da anders gestrickt
eine der improvisierten werfen zur
panzer abwehr war der molotow cocktail
eine flasche mit einer mischung aus
kerosin zäher und benzin darin man
konnte sie mit einem chemischen zünder
aus schwefelsäure und kalium chloratum
gehen lassen
ein etwas simples modelle ist eine
flasche benzin an der oben einbrennen
und lappen hängt eine waffe die seit dem
spanischen bürgerkrieg in den 1930 er
jahren weltweit bei konflikten und
krawallen eingesetzt wird aber es waren
die finnen die das volle potenzial der
brandbombe erkannten dass zeiten der
verzweiflung fordern verzweifelte mittel
und da ist der molotow cocktail kaum zu
toppen ein wirklich brandgefährliche art
den feind anzugreifen
um einen höchst wahrscheinlich
bewaffneten panzer nur mit einer flinte
und eine benzinbombe anzugreifen braucht
man echt muss man muss sich ziemlich nah
heranschleichen am den brandsatz auf den
empfindlichsten teil des panzers zu
werfen und das ist die motorabdeckung am
heck
[Musik]
manni faktor um ausreichend
molotow-cocktails produzieren zu können
wendet sich die finnische armee an die
staatliche alkohol brennerei in reiki
dort werden aus schnapsflaschen molotow
cocktails
eine richtige brandbomben
trotz ihrer vermeintlich überlegenen
ausrüstung erleidet die rote armee laut
schätzungen ein vielfaches an verlusten
was sie aber nicht davon abhält die
molotow cocktail fabrik ins visier zu
nehmen
[Musik]
die cocktails hatten einen haken weil es
eine staatliche schnaps fabrik war stand
ihr name auf den deckeln und die sowjets
fanden diese decke
das ist als würde man ein schild
hochhalten auf dem steht hallo der feind
ist hier drüben es war ein kinderspiel
die fabrik zu finden und die
sowjetischen bomber zu schicken
jetzt muss ganz schnell eine
verteidigungsstrategie für die stadt her
wenn man sich finnland so anschaut gibt
es ein offensichtliches problem für die
flugabwehr furchtbar viele bäume
die einzige möglichkeit das sichtfeld zu
erweitern und besseren
abschlussmöglichkeiten zu bekommen ist
also ein möglichst ohne punkt für die
flugabwehrgeschütze zu finden und ein
turm war da die einzige lösung
[Musik]
nur 500 meter von der schnaps fabrik
entfernt werden die rallye am aegi türme
hochgezogen jeder mit einer plattform
für eine flak geschütze an der spitze
eine todesfalle für jedes flugzeug das
zu nahe kommt
die flak ist ein artilleriegeschütz mit
hoher durchschlagskraft
zur abwehr von flugzeugen
die granate wird hoch in die luft
gefeuert und explodiert in der nähe des
flugzeugs die granatsplitter sollen die
maschine dann zum absturz bringen
fragt er während der beste schutz für
die fabrik in ramadi aber werden sie
auch rechtzeitig vor dem sowjet angriff
fertig sein
die finnen hatten höllische angst
russische bomber konnten ziele damals
nicht mit präzision angreifen den
finnischen städten drohte also ein
flächenbombardement
der krieg verlagert sich vom boden in
die luft und die finnen müssen erneut an
ihre kräfte aufbringen
[Musik]
um die molotow cocktail produktion in
reiki zu schützen werden buchstäblich
schwere geschütze aufgefahren
die 40 mm ist vermutlich eine der besten
flugabwehrkanonen die jemals entwickelt
wurden
sie war sehr fortschrittlich für ihre
zeit allerdings nicht vollautomatisch
die soldaten mussten von hand nach laden
im finnischen winter in eis und schnee
müssen sie furchtbar gefroren haben der
eiskalte wind traf sie da oben auf dem
turm mit voller wucht und man kann sich
nicht einfach komplett in fell ein höhen
die riecht schätzen die nach zielen
stehen und die soldaten die nach laden
müssen beweglich sein
das war für die mannschaft sicher
schrecklich stunden lang da oben
auszuharren und immer bereit für den
ernstfall sie mussten die bombe einfach
von dieser wichtigen apfel anlage
fernhalten
sie probiert er ihnen arbeitet für die
örtliche gemeinde und weiß viel über die
türme
[Musik]
wir sind jetzt auf einem der beiden
türme über diesen schacht hier wurde das
flakgeschütze nach oben gehievt und
anschließend auf dem dach montiert
kann ohne konnte sich um 360 grad drehen
flugzeuge können schließlich aus allen
richtungen kommen
aber kaum sind die türme fertigt ist der
winter krieg vorbei
und obwohl sowjetische flugzeuge die
umgebung von rajan eg neunmal
bombardieren hätten die finnen und ihre
molotow-cocktail fabrik stand
in den drei monaten des winter krieges
verlor die rote armee hunderte flugzeuge
die meisten schätzungen gehen von drei
bis 400 maschinen aus die vom finnischen
luft oder boden stellungen erwischt
wurden
ein jahr später kehrte krieg zurück
jetzt sind die türme voll abwehrbereit
[Musik]
die türme waren per telefon mit der
kommandozentrale verbunden überall in
finnland harten leute mit ferngläsern
und entfernungsmesser auf dächern aus
weil die finca ein radarsystem hatten
sie mussten sich ganz auf ihre guten
beobachter verlassen
sobald die am flugzeug sichteten gaben
sie die position durch und die flak
stellungen wurden alarmiert so wird
bomber im anflug wie weit wir schnell
wenn man sich das mal vorstellen auf
einem flakturm über den baumwipfeln mit
kaum deckung oder anderen schutz die
sowjet bomber sehen ganz genau von wo
aus sie beschossen werden und es ist
ganz klar dass sie einen ins visier
nehmen da braucht man echt nerven
die finnen hatten nicht viele
verteidigungsanlagen und eine oder zwei
kanonen wie hier im reiki konnten
natürlich auch nicht dutzende bombe
aufhalten wenn die es richtig darauf
anlegten hier ging es um abschreckung
jede form von widerstand wirkte sich
direkt auf die angreifer aus schon eine
einzige kanone konnte verhindern dass
eine anlage dem erdboden gleichgemacht
wurde
die flaktürme erfüllen ihren zweck
nachdem die stellung einsatzbereit ist
greift die rote amir ali ahmeti nicht
mehr an hin und wieder werden
kampfbomber gesichtet aber sie fliegen
zu hoch
grund zum jubeln haben die finnen
trotzdem nicht
sie haben als verbündete der nazis gegen
die russen gekämpft und stehen 1945 als
verlierer da die brennerei übersteht im
zweiten weltkrieg und produziert fortan
wieder statt für echte cocktails
die flaktürme werden für immer
versiegelt
heute sind die türme ein symbol für den
finnischen widerstand gegen die
sowjetunion
jeder leistete damals seinen beitrag und
die türme zeugen von den anstrengungen
der menschen an der front und in den
verbriefungen sie sind sinnbild für die
widerstandskraft der finden
[Musik]
almería an der südküste spaniens
in der andalusischen stadt kostet ein
gigantisches industriedenkmal vor
sichern
[Musik]
diese alte bahntrasse rund einen
kilometer lang
sie erstreckt sich wie eine
riesenschlange aus der stadt bis zum
wasser
[Musik]
die hochbahn windet sich durch die
straßen
sie endet dann abrupt in einem riesigen
block der hinaus in die bucht rat
gigantische stahlstreben stützen die
konstruktion kurz vor dem hafen teilt
sich die strecke in vier gleise als ob
die eiffelturm bang gekippt wäre es ist
alt das ist offensichtlich aber wofür
ist es gemacht und wo führt das hin
die spur führt zurück in die zeit der
industriellen revolution an der schwelle
zum zwanzigsten jahrhundert wandeln sich
viele staaten europas von der
agrarwirtschaft zum industrieland
das zauberwort heißt
massenproduktion das malochen in der
fabrik löst das alte handwerk in den
manufakturen ab das leben vieler
menschen verrichten um im akkord die
hochöfen gehen
die produktion neuer maschinen und
fabriken verschlingt unmengen von stahl
das wichtigste material der neuen zeit
[Musik]
das eisenerz für die stahlproduktion
wird anfang des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
zum begehrtesten rohstoff der welt
[Musik]
um mit dem ersten weltkrieg wird der
hunger nach stahl ins unermessliche
steigen
[Musik]
aber schon jetzt und zehn jahre vor
kriegsausbruch kommen die alten erzminen
südspaniens kaum mit der lieferung
hinterher
[Musik]
die groben linien im bergischen
landesinneren
bis dorthin sind es mehrere hundert
meter höhenunterschied das ist ein
problem die lage an sich ist zwar
günstig das eisenerz lässt sich leicht
aufspüren und abbauen aber man muss es
auch verschiffen können und dazu muss es
erstmal an die küste
[Musik]
der erste teil des problems lässt sich
noch recht einfach lösen zwischen den
ärzten und der nächsten hafenstadt
almeria wird eine eisenbahntrasse gebaut
aber dann wird es heikel
man kann sich heute kaum vorstellen wie
rückständig die häfen damals waren alles
was aufs schiff kam musste von hand
verladen werden
märz von güter and weinhof auf das
schiff zu bringen
köln zuerst wurde das material mit
muskelkraft entladen und dann
zwischengelagert bis das schiff anlegte
dann hieß es wieder anpacken und das
ganze zeug an bord schleppen
einen frachter mit eisenerz zu beladen
konnte über eine woche dauern das
prozedere war wahnsinnig uneffizient das
tolle an der neuen konstruktion war dass
sie die ganze lade routine
revolutionierte
die alte hafenanlage kann den
rohstoffbedarf einer politisch zunehmend
instabilen welt im turbo wandel nicht
mehr befriedigen kann der stahlkoloss
vielleicht helfen
1901 beginnen die bauarbeiten am
ladekabel später wird er als in kabul es
bekannt der englische team
[Applaus]
[Musik]
der bau nahm eine gravierende hürde den
zeit- und arbeitsintensive
gütertransport mit
hilfe von ingenieuren wurde versucht
eine bessere methode zu entwickeln
[Musik]
aus holz geplant aber in dieser gegend
gibt es stürme und andere dramatische
umwelteinflüsse deswegen entschied man
das metall doch besser geeignet wäre
der süden spaniens wirkt auf uns immer
so idyllisch aber im herbst und winter
kann es hier ganz schön heftige stürme
geben und wo sich ruhe und sturm ständig
abwechseln können enorme strömungen
entstehen eine holzkonstruktion hätte
das vielleicht nicht so lange
ausgehalten
das material der wahl ist stahl
die erfindung des hoffestes stars hatte
damals ähnliche folgen die für uns heute
die erfindung des computerchips eine
technik revolution die viele weitere
veränderungen nach sich zog und den
verbesserten stahl konnte man wunderbar
einsetzen um noch mehr erz zu schürfen
und noch mehr stahl zu produzieren
aber wenn die zukunft der spanischen
bergbauindustrie von diesem projekt
abhängt warum heißt es dann der
englische team
[Musik]
england hatte die modernsten hochöfen
und brauchte dringend ernst und es hatte
das nötige kleingeld um in ein land wie
spanien zu investieren die briten gaben
unsummen für infrastruktur aus um das
erz in die häfen und auf ihre schiffe zu
bekommen
die britischen ingenieure die nach der
lehre von gustave eiffel arbeiten denken
sich warum lassen wir nicht die waggons
und den anlegesteg die harte arbeit
machen schluss mit den lästigen erz
schaufeln die zukunft hält einzug
anstatt die schiffe von hand zugeladen
sollten die waggons bis zum ende des
spiels rollen und ihren inhalt über
einen riesigen trichter direkt in den
schiffsrumpf kippen
längsseits des piers werden 20 trichter
angebracht das erz soll allein durch die
schwerkraft in die behälter fallen dann
wählt man den richtigen trichter und
füllt das herz passgenau in den
frachtraum
kann dieses moderne system die örtliche
industrie retten
[Musik]
ich finde diese lösung genial über die
trichter kommt das schüttgut vom zug
direkt aufs schiff
im prinzip war das ein vorgeschmack
darauf wie große moderne helfen heute
arbeiten in einem container hafen wie
viel von los angeles sieht man wie
container aus und eingeladen werden ohne
dass jemand die fracht überhaupt
anfassen muss
es gab ein problem das gelöst werden
musste und die lösung steigerte die
effizienz um ein vielfaches vorher
dauerte das umladen zehn tage jetzt nur
noch zehn stunden und dabei war es noch
um ein viertel billiger man hätte also
echt was gespart
dank der neuen technik kann spanien
seine exporte enorm steigern von rund
500.000 tonnen
1875 auf und zehn millionen tonnen im
jahr 1913
[Musik]
aber wenn der kabul ist so ein
erfolgsmodell war warum ist er dann
heute leer und verlassen
eine zeit lang war er optimal auf die
bedürfnisse der räder abgestimmt aber
die technik entwickelt sich immer weiter
genau wie die märkte es gab andere minen
in anderen teilen der welt
im september 1970 wird der betrieb
eingestellt aber seine historische
bedeutung bewahrt den pier vor dem
abriss
[Musik]
pläne das industriedenkmal in ein
kulturzentrum mit gastronomie
umzuwandeln scheitern
[Musik]
wie lange wird der bauern noch verlassen
am strand stehen
[Musik]
ich finde es beeindruckend dass der
kabel ingles rund 70 jahre in betrieb
war wenn man bedenkt wie rasant sich die
technologie damals entwickelte merkt man
dass diese erfindung ihrer zeit weit
voraus war und mit ihr eine wirklich
dringendes problem gelöst wurde
[Musik]
ingenieurs- und
bauprojekte den verfall preisgegeben
sie erzählen von krieg und krisen aber
auch vom erfindergeist und fortschritt
vom allem wozu menschen fähig sind
[Musik]